it's time for the lawn gene conosco a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
monday wednesday and fridays a
presentation of the lawn gene which nor
watch company maker of lon gene the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lon gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the wrong
gene Cronus cope Larry lesser from the
CBS television news staff and Kenneth
Crawford national affairs editor of
Newsweek magazine our distinguished
guest for this evening is the honorable
guy MJ lept senator from Iowa probably
not since the days of the Spanish Civil
War has so much thinking centered about
those two words intervention or
non-intervention now President
Eisenhower has said that Indochina is
the cork in the bottle that keeps almost
all of Asia from communist control our
guest tonight senator Gillette is one of
the ranking Democrat members of the
powerful Senate Foreign Relations
Committee and so for a start senator if
I may I'd like to ask you what you think
we should do in Indochina well of course
the Larry the answer to what we what we
should do now is an entirely different 2
from the question as to what we should
have done in the past but we do have to
face the situation as it is there today
and as you've just said it's a very
serious one the necessary thing in my
opinion is to have a definite program a
definite policy that will end the
confusion so far as our people are
concerned they'll have some idea what
we're trying to do as well as our allies
they can be assured of some definite
plan as it is at the present it is very
indefinite less energy left you said not
long ago that you favored turning over
the problem of Indochina to the United
Nations do you feel still feel that
might accomplish anything I feel it's
essential we the United Nations
my opinion it marks the high point in
international cooperation for world
security and I think international
cooperation is essential the world
security for more involvement we are not
using it at the present time in the
Indochina situation wherein it differs
very materially from the situation that
pertained in Korea at the time we became
involved there when we went in under the
aegis of the United Nations working for
united nations principles with 16
associates that we're contributing
military forces and some 60 other
nations that were contributing at least
moral support whereas we're in Korea
we've made no attempt to bring this to
the United Nations we've been proceeding
unilaterally in the aid that we have
given France and Vietnam of course as a
subsidiary France senator some six weeks
ago I think you made a speech in what
you said time was running out here isn't
it now a question of perhaps time having
run out I'm afraid that there's too much
truth in that but it is true as you
suggested that on the floor of the
Senate I said at that time time is
running out and I felt that there were
three things that we could do even then
we had time before Geneva one was to
give assurance to the people of the
associated States of Indochina that we
would support their aspirations for full
independence to bring the matter before
the United Nations and bring the United
Nations in under the the obligations
that we all had incurred and then to try
to build up a an area regional defense
pact under the United Nations that was
not done at the don't you feel senator
that we're now beyond the place where
direct intervention as a question here
yes and yet at the same time we're in a
desperate situation we have been
carrying our carrying right this minute
seventy percent of the burden of that
war in in cost I don't know how and our
people are asking can our people are
asking how did we become involved how
did we become subrogated why did that
suddenly become our responsibility
France has been fighting in Indochina
for seven and a half years those people
have been trying to secure their
independence how did we happen to find
it our war at the present time and what
are we going to do about it we have
spent this last year over a billion
dollars in support and the future thing
about it is that it hasn't gone to
Vietnam it's gone to France and France
has used it in there any way that she
sees fit well a senator there seems to
be some doubt actually if we could get a
majority vote in the United Nations with
so many frightened Asiatic nations there
now what do you think of the possibility
of getting a regional United action or
united front in Indonesia I think we can
accomplish that of mr. Liu sewer I'm
sure we can we have proceeded in
negotiation developing regional packs
under the United but it is like to point
out only a few months ago we wouldn't
allow France and Britain to go into our
answers packed with the new zealand and
australia in the pacific and now we seem
to want them in very badly we are urging
them to come in and there will be some
hesitancy and bringing them in the
present plan as i understand it is not
only to bring france and great britain
in but of the associated States of
Indochina and Philippines and the
possibility of Japan but of course along
with new zealand and australia the and
the possibility of burma the whole idea
being that we can bring in the states
that have a community of interest in
that area time as as Ken suggested is
pretty well run out well but it's you
against the guess is that it is a pretty
desperate situation but is there any
optimism to be drawn from the Geneva
Conference so we note that the Russians
seem to be more amenable
to an armistice there which might be
controlled by neutral States they've
said do you feel that there is any
reason for optimism over the results of
this conference of Geneva so far as I've
seen any reports from Geneva I see no
occasion for optimism at all apparently
the communist group and the communist
satellites are in the saddle layer and
so far they've up to the present time
they've given every evidence they expect
to remain in the saddle are going to
dictate the terms we have a very able
man there in general beetle Smith very
keen and very able but the no man can
accomplish anything unless you have a
definite purpose and plan in which is to
work senator as a practical matter next
in the Far East what is it a security
pact of some kind and a new line a new
defense line somewhere I take that's
about the only thing you can do I think
it's absolute folly can to talk about a
blockade to blockade the coast and
economic blockade or to turn loose janka
checks of forces on the mainland the
first place they cannot accomplish
anything we have our airplanes or our
airplane carriers at the present time in
the Tonkin Gulf but if we brought all
the naval force of America into a
blockade there it could well bring in
the chinese empire into full-scale war
and if it so it would inevitably bring
the russian empire into and that would
be third world war that'll be third
senator we seem to be thinking of in
terms of too much too late but while
we're thinking of what we haven't done
in Indochina what about places we can do
something this needs to be a very bad
situation now in the Middle East where
most of the world's great oil reserves
are underground would you form any kind
of a coalition to secure that area well
of course as you know we are we have
made rather mark progress in that
direction we started with the NATO
packed then later we extended it to
include Greece and Turkey now we are
working and will
measurable success to bring Pakistan and
possibility of Iraq and that'll extend
it still even so there doesn't seem to
be any disposition on our part to secure
a firm peace in the Middle East visa V V
between the Israelis and the Arabs that
seemed that situation seems to be
deteriorating rapidly it is and i had
the rather dubious privilege of visiting
nine of those countries last fall in
that area in the near eastern area and
the situation there is rather desperate
the if there's no improvement in
relations between the arab states and
israel in fact every one of the Arab
states told me the leaders told me at
that time that they were defeated by
Israel militarily but that they were
going to bring her to her knees
economically through the blockading her
and destroying her industrially senator
well has some time that I'd like to turn
the subject to another one and that's
the view of the hearings now taking
place in Washington I'd like to ask you
a question some people are saying that
the caliber of our representatives in
Congress now has deteriorated now you've
been in Congress for more than 20 years
do you feel that the we no longer have
men of the caliber of Norris Bora the
elder lafollette oh no I wouldn't say
that the Congress is a cross-section of
men throughout the country the length
and breadth of the country the districts
and the States certainly selectmen in
whom they have confidence we have poor
congressman we have very able
congressman we've had them in the past
and we have them at the present time of
course it's a probably a fortunate thing
the distance lends enchantment and we
forget the weaknesses as time goes by
but I would say that this con this
Congress compares very favorably with
the preceding Congress's you feel there
are giants in this Congress as well as
they were in the past them yes we have
Giants in this Congress and we have
members in this
congressman perhaps we could dispense
with without any pain they would thank
you very much senator letra proud to
have you here tonight the opinions
expressed on the lawn gene krona scope
were those of the speakers the editorial
board for this edition of the lawn gene
krona scope was Larry lesser and Kenneth
Crawford our distinguished guest was the
honorable guy MJ left senator from Iowa